[Musique]
saihi zareen ça va tu es bon là
tu ferais mieux de prendre un peu d'élan
tu va m'expliquer ce que je dois faire
jusqu'à pas de plus ça peut parfois tout
changer et occupe toi de ton volant t'es
sérieux
nous enquêtons sur un réseau de voitures
volées dans toute l'europe
et j'entends toujours là non jour après
jour à jour celui des deux frères fasse
taire
demi frère
tu sais que tu bonne andrew on est
l'équipe j'ai essayé de le convaincre
il n'a rien voulu savoir parfois contre
aride et yb bâle etc lesquels il vaut
mieux pas avoir de problème intense car
ce n'est pas nous contrarier nos alors
comme ça vous êtes frère on n'a pas
grandi ensemble en fait c'est pas grave
qui commandent mois vous m'avez volet on
pouvait pas savoir que c'était votre
voiture
on peut faire quelque chose pour vous
inscrire vous dites que vous voulez vous
laisser de ferrari 62 directement sous
son nez
moi vous savez une semaine c'est sûr
qu'il va nous falloir une équipe pour
réussir un coup pareil
une bouillabaisse
c'est parti
[Musique]
la compagnie change 3,12 c'est non elles
sont sortis encore une va s'adapter
[Musique]